a tough question is what do you do when
you're part of a group and you're not
the leader of the group and and the
leader and the others are moving in a
particular direction and you think that
it has ethical problems if we take a
look at the Challenger story there were
two engineers who were fighting against
the launch but it turns out that they
weren't particularly well organized in
their data presentation and the fact
that they weren't well prepared the fact
that that their arguments were primarily
effective rather than rather than
reasoned really impeded their ability to
have an impact the evening before the
launch of the of the Challenger there
was a meeting and some of the engineers
at Morton Thiokol who provided the
engine believed that there were problems
with the o-rings at temperatures below
53 degrees they provided that argument
and NASA under political pressure
dramatically wanted to launch the most
astounding was the engineers were
looking at the seven previous launches
out of 24 where there had been problems
and they couldn't discern an appropriate
pattern what they failed to do was to
ask what any engineer should have known
and that is if you want to know whether
temperature is related to 10 to oring
failure you need to look at the
successes and the failures throughout
this process there was virtually no
discussion about the fact that seven
astronauts had their lives at stake the
discussion turned entirely technical it
had very much of a managerial feel to it
and the ethical part of the decision
faded from awareness so the question is
what kind of an intervention might have
been effective and and the amazing part
of the Challenger story is that the
intervention was shockingly easy all
that was really needed was for somebody
to say if we want to know is temperature
related to a ring failure what data do
we need and the answer is quite obvious
we need a look at the data for all 24
launches rather than just the 7 launches
with problems to see if there's a
difference in temperature between
successful and unsuccessful launches had
somebody asked that
it would have been very easy to get the
other 17 data points and when you look
at all all 24 data points together the
decision to not launch becomes extremely
obvious so one critical issue for group
members who think that they're going to
be confronting a situation where they're
gonna have a limited opportunity to
convince others to move in a different
direction is to make sure that you've
put all your data together
you have a good recent argument so that
people can see the wisdom of a more
ethical direction